okay four people joining this live
stream this is continuing discussion
about database integration in the
upcoming version of Wolfram language so
first up is a discussion of all kinds of
names of functions related to this um
and we have a proposal here for a
variety of these names hmm okay so
you're proposing something where we Wow
okay um well let's discuss what some of
these mean okay so what you're proposing
entities sorted entity class so the main
issue is that we want to make these
nouns right so explain to me for example
if I take this entity store uh wherever
it is and then I want to okay so those
are entity value things but let's say I
want to take this entity store which
hopefully hopefully this is running
correctly here no why is that not what
he didn't register it okay um
see where was that where was the
registration yes with all the way
downtown
you
um so women you always have to do that
you always have to entity make it into
an entity store and then we say entity
register of that entity store so we'd
say here and to register of that store
okay great and it returns okay so now
you are proposing and so now if I say
enter the value of person great okay
our friends are just numbers for some
reason okay who knows why because those
are the value of the thing on the
database the relation the friend
entities are called person - friend okay
so what I could do right now will be
entity sort by and so if I say entity
sort by and I say person comma and then
I say is it hash friend no it's just
string friend why it's a property could
be entity property but it's you don't
need a function there
how about if I wanted to sort it by the
I mean okay so that would become sort
identity okay so if I say entry sort by
and now I say enter the value of that
OMA / , what would I do full name for
example why did that work always why did
that work that way why did that work
that way that should be that should sort
it by friend number right oh maybe it
was already sorted it was already sorted
but it was kinda sorted if you look at
it it's not like the same like the last
one is different okay fine
so that's sorted by friend number okay
so your proposal is that that would
become a sorted entity class so question
for Michael and Tony is that something
we can support in the rest of our and
digital framework yes all of these new
database entity functions have a
corresponding entity store and after
implementation we already have it well
the Alpha site is evaluative then the
Alpha I'm from Tennessee Valley
Authority client site but this is a
detail in principle yes it all supported
okay so so you do you support these new
names here
well they would be renamed at the same
time for all began I understand that I'm
asking you whether you like the new
names
I don't know okay so that's okay so you
have you have nothing to say about them
or you don't like them I don't have a
good reason against them but somehow I
don't feel so good about him
I mean you say that you know the part on
the ticket discussion I mean you can
expand on that may be but entity class
in the name so one of the proposed names
is aggregated entity class or something
like that however if you say entity list
of that thing then you can't do anything
because we don't have a representation
of the entities that currently
aggregated entity class what is an
aggregate what is a class imagine you
can do something like a great country by
continent and then you have some some
aggregations like you can get the
average population or the maximum well
isn't that more like group to enter the
class it's it's because it's the
aggregation is the important feature
here it's like group by isn't it not
quite because it's I mean it's similar
to group by but the most important
feature here and it's the one that it's
not that the only one that's not
optional
easy is in the aggregations that you do
so you can even say aggregate everything
and so that's the two arguments version
if you look at the examples on the on
the right then you get basically an T
class that contains one single entity
which is all together wait where did
this is this what you typed in here or
you typed it in okay from last time yeah
so there are two versions one is like
with two arguments one is with three are
we talking about let's go back to them
which one of these do you think is the
most straightforward to look at I think
probably select sort take are the easier
to look at okay so this one you're
proposing that it be called filtered
we've never used the word filtered
entity class
I think that filtered is better than
selected because that's it's selected
select has a very precise and different
meaning in in sequel and so this way
nobody would get confused yeah the word
theater has been proposed for this
property goes to predicate notation that
we use in implicit entity classes this
would be something slightly different
I'm not a big fan of filter because one
day when we do more advanced maths we
need photos everywhere in Oporto
algebras and all those things right okay
so let's go back here and ask the
question so is entity class the right
base for these names
what is one yes okay so fundamentally
what all these things are doing is
creating an entity class
by some operation on an existing entity
class yes
or more yeah okay so okay so you know
the principle here is no week we could
summarize these as operations on entity
classes
so what other operations on entity
classes do we have do you understand my
question do you mean other than those
listed above yes other ones that you're
introducing other ones so sorry wait
wait it's Ian I think one more important
thing is that these are did these
operations or entity class always return
I mean they don't return but
symbolically represent a new entity
class and so their operations that like
antilles store entity value that
actually perform ok come evaluation and
these are just basically I mean if you
look at it algebraically they go from
the space of entity classes to the space
when it's exhausted
so what would we call and not operations
on that their transformations and they
all accept from turn across which would
be entity merged ok so these are these
are now then we have functions event
functions evaluated on entity classes is
that correct yes which is a different
thing and those functions are entity
value and to a list and what else and
the entity property all that sensitive
value function that's also entity value
really underneath now let's look at
entry function is entity function
something that immediately evaluates or
not the entity function behaves exactly
like a property so if you are if you
leave it alone if you don't apply to
some ok so so there's a different thing
these are immediately evaluating right
yeah and then we
setting up a structure which is entity
function right mmm I mean entity
function is really like if you have on
one side of the of the algebra anty anty
class from the other side like the dual
is entity functionality property anti
property class I guess so it's like this
is okay so the point of this is it is
analogous it is a computed like a
computed entity property correct
yes exactly okay all right so now we got
these transformations on entity classes
so the first step is entity class itself
all right so if I say entity class now
what what can I say here so I say entity
class of country comma g8 for example
right that represents an entity class
so for example if I say entity value of
that comma population I will get the
population of the whole know I get that
so if I do this so I have a function
here if I can say can I say total there
hello Tony it's like you can do it but
it's kind of the hack in a sense and
that the more proper way of doing it
would be with NC Agra aggregator and
z-class
okay Michael and Tony could you speak up
please yes I think this is a temporary
syntax not really documented we should
use entity aggregate or whatever that's
called from now on okay so the thing the
form that you want to have here is
entity hmm you would like it to say some
can we try to prevent that that echo um
okay you are suggesting perhaps a name
like aggregated entity class
of
I'm not really a big fan of this this
and then population right you're
suggesting that that's what that would
look like
correct no second arguments in a second
argument to aggregate density class or
you say something like total population
goes to what are you talking about yeah
first you have to say what you're
aggregating and then how you call this
aggregate property and then you can with
that's horrible else would you like to
explain how do we do okay so what we
really want to be able to say is you
know aggregate by total I mean this is
the this is the other way round of what
you're talking about is take that set of
things and you know for this property
find the total or is it the case that
what you say is that what we should be
doing is to just say total of but that
then becomes a client-side computation
right yep okay so what is the
server-side version of that computation
it would be an T value let me show you I
can figure that let me figure out see if
I can figure it out because what you're
saying is then then you say it would be
an entity function is that right
No okay tell me how to do it that okay
entity value of now it's called entity a
great of g8 and then comma no no you
have to wrap Integra gate around g8
you
okay yes kana then total population as a
string that's something I'm making up
now yep oh for God's sake no this is a
total mess
go on goes to yeah
ante function oh for goodness sake you
can't be serious okay go on then see
karma see total total of C population
where's the population would see it
supplied to see
okay so that's a joke and then I have to
then say comma total population there
right yeah okay so that's a joke all
right so what do we actually have to do
to get this to work so I will comment
here I think that what you want to do is
a convenient shortcut in cases where you
have for example just one property and
the aggregator is something simple and
what this is is I don't understand that
I want to know how do we do the thing
that people actually want to do right
how do we do the simple thing because
what you're currently proposing doesn't
solve that problem clean it so how we
solve that problem you know we've got a
collection here of functions right which
operations a shorter version of that if
you want go ahead entity value yeah of
g8 yeah and then you can say entity
property count 3 comma population comma
total okay less of a hack
okay does Tony think that's a hack or
not
so the empty list is missing before the
total because in the third argument we
have qualifiers in this case no
qualifiers in dental
yes it is very unintuitive in some sense
because I think okay so listen listen
reality check guys okay you know
database programming is typically a
total mess
you know it's typically done it
typically involves these you know
elaborate join operations that are
frankly quite hard for most people to
understand and you know it typically
ends up with junk like this what we need
to do is to get beyond and above this so
you know we've got some distance there
but I think this makes it clear that we
haven't solved the problem yet I think
that I mean see and honestly I think
that this if you want to do database
programming you're gonna you're gonna
there is one good reason why people have
big complicated things in one goal and
that's atomicity like if you if you
optimize for one-liners you will never
get atomic results out well that's what
we want to see why why I don't I don't
stand alone okay suppose you're you're
querying a database that changes every
millisecond yep if you get out the total
with one one-liner then you do a
completely different thing that's
another one liner you end up with it is
inconsistent you won't understand why
you said that why isn't there a domestic
a with whatever you you know whatever
query you're making right should be
economic yeah but if you if you don't
give people the possibility of getting
together in the total population and the
mean population then you get to things
that are out of sync okay you know what
you know what this argument is such a
crock if I might say so I mean your
argument is that give people you know
give people unbelievably convoluted
company you know syntax in order that we
don't have to solve the problem of
getting if they ask for the total and
the mean together that we don't have to
solve the problem of getting that
atomically is that what you're saying no
what I'm seeing is that do you want
people to use this for doing data base
programming or do you want it for people
to answer I want I want people to
actually use it which means it needs to
do better that you know frankly they
could be using SQL for a lot of the sky
by the time yes feel is a great language
yeah well so why don't we just why why
do we do this project why don't we just
give them database link I'll be done
with it because there are a bunch of
things that are complicated to get into
the system after like you you execute
the SQL and you get a bunch of stuff out
that doesn't happen yet so this is our
objective our objective is to make
something that people you know that
doesn't involve this kind of convoluted
nonsense okay so let's let's try to
figure out what you're doing right now
is building an intermediate layer
between SQL and the the level of you
know polish that we like to have some
distance but it's not getting all the
way as you and I completely disagree I
think I mean if you want shorthand
syntax is we can add them later but
that's so far we density class because
like we haven't even thought about how
to do or with NC class okay well fine
that's what I'm saying to you is you're
building an intermediate level here and
let's get that as clean as we can but
let's think about how we build something
that actually will solve the final
problem so let's look at this case okay
as an example and see what we would like
this to look like okay what I thanks
Aaron is that you're aiming towards
removing the intermediate total
population from the game in the case of
a single single aggregation yes that's
what I'm that's what I would like to do
and that's probably possible okay well
let's think about how to do it for a
second as an example okay so what you're
suggesting is this aggregated entity
class okay does it represent I mean it's
a kind of a weird construct because what
you're saying is what you really want is
to aggregate only in this one property
because you don't really want to say and
let's say that's what you're doing
that's what you're doing you only agree
on that promise the other the others get
lost that aggregate that entity class
has only one property in the store
population okay
fine but the fact that you have to name
I don't really understand what an
advocate identity class is if it's only
about one property it doesn't seem like
I mean if you put the third argument
first of all the second argument can be
a least and and and other than that you
can put the third arguments and
aggregates over something okay so what
you're doing in these cases is you're
you're basically generating intermediate
keys in the database this thing total
population is you know you're not having
a symbolically named thing so for
example one could say you know one could
say that aggregated entity clause
was you know one could imagine something
let's see the aggregated every class has
one property is that correct total which
is total populations that is that what
you do is yes okay fine
I don't know seems like the wrong way
around to do this one thing you could do
is that we could make a short end that
is karma total goes to population and
that doesn't mean the property well okay
so that let's imagine we did that okay
or population goes to total or something
a pollution was VM maybe maybe
population was that is better
yeah right yeah South Chandler on our
live stream comments on you know
leveraging the data set query syntax for
this stuff to what extent are we doing
that yeah I think we decided student to
do that later because right now we
decided to expose databases through the
entity front-end but we haven't Urmi is
layer and plans to later support data
set course index yeah to an extent I
mean there are I mean most of the
operations you can do in that means that
you cannot do on a database because its
data set is hierarchical and and the
database you always have to deal with
things that are in first normal form and
that's also what ng class that's your
match hey Steven I just wanted to remind
you that like a year and a half ago and
the very start of this project I
actually already did a short demo where
I was compiling small subset of data set
operations to that so it's it's it's
very possible you know to my mind the
way this should work is you know some
data set operations are compiled able
some are not if they compile fantastic
if they don't compile people can be told
whoops this isn't going to compile it's
going to work on the client side you go
to download a bunch of data and do it on
the client side and so long as we can
message that properly I think it will be
fine yeah I just think we decided that
we supported that after her walk
okay well so long as we don't have an
incompatible you know I'd like to
understand that syntax so we don't have
something incompatible I mean how do you
imagine that would work well go ahead I
mean I already like we already saw it
working the only thing that gave real
issue where I had to extend data set
language was joint and like relational
lookout okay so what you're saying is
given this entity store right and this
is a question for Tony also right
given this entity store here right
you're saying that you could then do
data set like queries on that entity
store is that correct yeah that's what
I'm saying in principle give me an
example of what what we might do that
well for example it can do something
like select and then of some criteria
like let's say yeah but the thing is
Stephen you can do it on energy store
directly you have to choose the data set
first like for example person so you say
any distortion something like that and
then on that you can do that so what
does entity store a person do right now
I don't think it does anything Tony can
you speak up please
document it baby for that okay and what
would you expect that to do I mean that
that the issue with the entity store as
the entity store as a graph basically of
relations is that right right so for now
there are some basic operations
supported I mean each entity store that
maybe you can do with entity value you
can wrap an entity store in there and
some basic operations to wrap so like
off entity comma property okay so entity
value of this thing wait a certain what
are you saying here so you're saying if
I were to index the entity store by an
entity prop by prop by an entity name
is that right no basically if you have a
call like entity value of entity 1 comma
property 1 then you can replace that
entity value head with an actual entity
store and it should still work if the
entities are next or a live stream is
making a suggestion here for but but
soon one thing I think the correct thing
here would be to create data set that is
backed by a single type in the entity
store like have a constructor data set
of that and then I agree so that's what
I would think yes so it looks like
something like this
where where that takes some slice of the
entity store is that what you're
suggesting yeah and the second argument
could be person or something like that
so what does that mean what would that
mean that would mean what would that
mean what that mean to sort the entity
store so that the first level of the
data set is person or what no that means
that you have entity store as a
collection of data sets each data set
corresponds to a single type but who is
that when you lose relations in this way
you only lose that if you don't extend
the data set course index by relation
operations no what I mean is that if you
construct the data set only with person
how this person know about from the
action yeah I mean that data set because
it's constructed from the entity store
it obviously contains the entire India
store information and then why do you
need to construct it with person as well
just construct it with the entity store
and then first you have to kill the
level out to get person because the data
set like the rectangular data set is
Allah aligns best was a single table not
with the collection of tables well
didn't you have a data set that's
hierarchically three year rectangular
ones yeah but I mean I think that given
that the other things we're doing at
least for relational world is all tables
that extra level and making that data
set hierarchical doesn't make much sense
because but it does it does because
we're trying to map it
okay Tony can you say what you imagine
the mapping from entity stores to
dentists that says I don't have an
opinion it's more relational I mean look
the 95 percent of that is like single
tables connected through relations so
why would want to connect a single data
set from a datastore
I think it will just complicate
everything but what are you proposing
that we'd be able to do queries directly
on the day entity store
No I propose that we have to we have we
will extend the syntax of a data set
through a few operations such as
relational lookup basically and then you
make queries on a single data set of say
person but if it needs to fetch
something from another data set it'll
just look look it up and because it was
constructed from the energy story it
will know what to do well I don't fully
understand that but let's loop back to
the original question that we had here
okay so we're trying to define these
things which I understand are let's look
at our example here wherever it was are
basically
modified versions
of the entities store ar-ar-ar
transformations on the entity store
representing pieces pieces of the entity
store transformed in some way right now
you're at yeah in a sense yes well no no
I want to be clear is that an anti
stories of collection of entity classes
basically when she types really it's a
collection of entity types and the
entity types may have entity classes in
each entity type as a trivial entity
class which is just into the classrooms
name comma all okay oh if somebody's
asking a live stream can put entities
into a data set yes that works just fine
the um okay
so what this is what this is asking for
again is these are trying to represent
various kinds of rearrangements virtual
rearrangements of the entity store that
is there is a direct way of accessing
the entity store and doing operations on
it such as entity value and entity list
right the concept here is to transform
the entity store or transform classes to
create what is it really doing is it
creating I mean is it is it really
transforming the entity store no yeah
it's not no it's not just from in the
store store stays as it is
I know it stays as it is yeah yeah
you'll it doesn't it never operates on
the whole entity store integrates on one
or two classes from the entity store
okay so the concept is then I mean I
don't understand why I couldn't operate
on the whole entity store but but but
because these are class level operations
it's like there are any class
celebration NT level creation and see
property what's an example of an entity
level operation dated I think we have
stuff like that um okay wait a minute so
that that okay so hold on so these are
modifiers okay so we've got a separate
thing as modifiers to properties right
of which you say dated is one example is
just a shortcut for the date qualifier
of properties okay okay so now let's go
back here so you say don't see that the
entity group is an energy level modifier
take some bunch of entities it returns
in cinclant okay I know that Michael and
Tony have to go at the top of the hour
and where we really need to okay let's
let's continue here
okay so we're saying these are things
which create in a sense a virtual entity
class on which operations can be done is
that correct except except you killed
entity least I'm sorry what are you
talking about you decided not to have
until this work on this why not because
I mean they can't be easily represent
the string types so basically if you if
you do Ltd least or say you're not
greater than two the class we agree
eight countries by continent then you
will get aggregates that are indexed by
continent so what and so the problem is
that the first argument would be have to
be something that is not a string so I
don't know I like the first argument I
don't understand so so hold on second so
so the concept here that the principal
would be these are these return
essentially virtual you know entity
classes
that is that right the on which you can
do enter the value an entity list soon
I think this agreement was or on the
level of single entities and what you
didn't like or a single entities with
complex first arguments okay but that's
not what we're talking I mean what's up
of an aggregated entity class of
aggregated entities from an aggregated
entity class that was a greedy get Adam
some property
sorry so that I can okay imagine you
aggregate the countries by some property
or maybe even some entity function so
where the by the third argument is it's
something now what is what is the type
of these what is the entity type of this
okay so let's look at your case that
you're talking about so you're saying
entity in the in the current way and
today I regret what are you saying here
country
mmm and something like population was
total like this yeah and then comma
continent so here now what do I do with
this tell me what to do next
I mean this wouldn't work because use
the shorthand predation total but okay
so if I put in all this nonsense yes
okay then you can get a population out
of it by so then tell me what to do next
open at the end open square bracket open
string total population okay like that
you
okay so now what's this doing so amazing
is that it's getting the results by
continent but now well what was that
what's the problem here yeah what if you
do at least instead of this what you get
out if I get and if I do entity list
instead of a total population there yes
yes so there are some objects new
objects that have these values and what
might this do I mean I think it should
return a list of I don't know seven
entities where the first argument is the
query itself comma Europe America okay
so intimate because because the problem
is that this is a type what is the
problem here the problem is that this
type of entity what why isn't this I see
continent no explain the point I mean in
this case you could you could
technically say it's content though it's
not because it doesn't have the same
properties but imagine you aggregated on
something which is like I don't know you
rounded the population to the nearest
million and you're aggravated by that
that's something that doesn't even have
a name yes okay
okay so then what so then what's the
type of that what's the type of those
entities those are entities that have
actually only two properties one is
total population and the other one so
these are virtual entities basis yes and
so the question is you have no big
problem with virtual entities the
problem that we ran into is that whether
the first argument should somewhat
simplify when you do something like that
so like right now when we do antilles
two entity class even if you had filters
in the NT class that that returns
entities this isn't actually correct I
mean what what the actual correct thing
here is entity xxx Europe you would have
and there you have right right right
that's the point so you're saying this
is an extended instead of that being an
entity of country it is
a decorated country because it's a it's
not a county it doesn't have the same
yeah I understand yeah so the issue then
okay so Tony if we were to introduce
sort of symbolically represented sort of
virtual entity types so that this is
this calls for basic lave virtual entity
types that correct yeah but the the main
problem that we have is that currently
the way entity class works with filters
is that it's somewhat simplifies the
first argument if it can
what do you mean that it's like if you
say I want the entity class of g8g it
would not appear in the first argument
okay
I'll come again I know Tony has to go so
can we please get some feedback from him
on this unless you already left
yeah okay can you give some feedback on
this please so my my point is that
Europe in this case it's a string stood
still looks nice but continent could be
anything
and that could be markets so we
basically would allow arbitrary
expressions in the second argument of
entity the first argument in the second
argument as well as the first argument
both argue yes in the first argument too
so that means there there will be a
complicated design process and the
Christmas sorry I'm sorry why is that
complicated design I don't understand
what's the complexity here the first
argument in the second argument of
entity will have to correspond in some
way and if you start nesting aggregates
and joins that might become complicated
but you know that I I've already solved
this problem because since you can
register a complex query then that just
works complex entity type you mean you
can register you can register in any
type of this class like things as a new
entity type and so I already solved that
problem comes out as a list and there is
a clear order of evaluation that tells
you what part of the list means what we
had also the
something called MTV ad which took an
association with the fully qualified
properties inside so there was no
confusion as to what it was doing I mean
we had proposed multiple solutions the
things we really got stuck on is that
when we went least on on something that
is filtered somehow should we keep the
filter in the first argument of the
resulting entities or not that's what's
the thing what's the argument I mean
look you know the print form is one
thing keeping that structure there it
seems like there's no way out of that
yes you agree that there's no way out of
it yes and that was our or original
proposal to you in the first place that
we keep the structure as it is but then
the problem is that is far if I remember
correctly Tori has the head the idea
that in some cases like if you have just
a filter you can argue that this is
still the same type which I don't think
is correct but there are arguments for
it and against it maybe that's a feature
that's not that no don't affect this
design everyone on earth is this result
what what continent has 3,000 people if
it isn't Antarctica and then if that's
the case what continent is missing green
lands maybe it's not a continent Oh
for the population continent in there
instead of just total population and you
see in the know
but back is that
well that's the data oh it's old the
countries that don't have a continent so
they they are aggregated is missing
which i think is incorrect well but
that's a question for the aggregator
isn't it I mean I think that missing is
really a special value and the fact that
we actually propagate it weirdly
operations like if it's not total and
there are three missions to get added as
three ties miss languages
okay but that's okay there's something
to look at but but alright it fine um
okay so let's go back a Michael Antonio
so yeah so what I was saying is that one
problem that we have is that we have a
precedent for MSD class of stripping
some of these filters away because when
you do every class of an implicit
identity then again the resulting
entities are of type C country they're
not of the identity class country
when you do implicit entities so you're
saying if I say okay so I say entity
country population rates no no see even
say and least yeah and in class or any
class in an entity stuff that so what do
you think you're saying entity much
greater than 1 billion well ok so
greater than
okay and then you want me to say so this
entity class it's just a class I
personally I find this thing rather
confusing and I think we should actually
this should be more decorated because
it's it's unclear didn't a thing here I
mean again this is a none evaluated
object and so now I can say enter the
list of that right and now if I want to
get the total please these two entities
are of type country before that there
were ever was a filter on them that's
the whole discussion point well that
they forgot that because that way we can
canonically we can compare them with
other things if they got a bunch of
filter crud in them that's not better
work but still on the other hand imagine
that there is a country which is just
about to join this club which is just
the borderline population and then
yesterday it was still filtered out and
today someone else was born and it's now
in this list yes so we want to do
evaluation like you know it's the same
thing for any of these things there's a
moment at which it's evaluated and
there's a structure that can be
re-evaluated am i making sense use those
two I mean you've got to be able to
actually get results yes but still on on
the other hand when you are determining
the existence of the entity what this
means is that that country
technically stops existing in like it
doesn't yet exist in this entity list
because it's not yet there and then it
will be exists there after someone else
is born okay
imagine you have a list of customers who
haven't paid you but still owe you money
you you get out the end list and then
you want to note the amount that they
owe you if you do this in two steps and
you forget about the filter you will
have people that have paid you in the
mean time
okay guys look both cases are relevant
right both cases are relevant both you
freeze it then you compute from it and
you maintain the thing unavailing
cases are desirable so let's make sure
we can support both cases by making
sense but see one it was not exactly the
point we were trying to make that we
should have NT least until you simplify
no I'm saying you could have something
which is like your collection of
functions up here that don't actually do
anything right at some point you have to
resolve and do something right so
there's there's a class of functions
right which we can think of as
transformation functions which don't
actually do anything right there's a
transformation function and there's
essentially a what we might call a
resolution function
yeah the main problem is that really
entity list does partial resolution and
and the question is I don't know I mean
let's let's not address that issue right
now okay
that's entity list is its own separate
thing let's address okay what does
entity does not resolve
but why don't we just decide that the
resolution functions our entity value
and entity list yeah the question is how
much does entity list resolve as much as
it can as much as it can would be to go
down to the entity property Association
easy no because no that's not right
it resolves as much as it can without
you know while maintaining so your point
is that an entity list that you might
have an aggregated entity whose
aggregator is still a symbolic
aggregator right right so so the point
here is entity list might end up where
they symbolically defined entity yeah
but the point is that also that if you
do NT least some anti class with the
filter you can resolve the filter right
away if the filter is nested with the
duration there's no weight result yes I
got it I understand the point right so
entity list so to my mind so long as we
indicate to the user what's going on
we're in good shape that is you know
there are some things where you know you
end up with a symbolic variable and
there other ones where you end up with
numbers like three right and people can
tell the difference between three and a
symbolic variable and so similarly here
you're saying entity list might resolve
all the way to just you know to pure you
know a sort of invariant entities pure
entities or it might end up with
something which has some you know what
let's say pure why am I thinking fixed
stars but you know pure entities that
are fixed for all time verses there's no
such thing in the industrial warned it's
things that are fixed for all time or
whatever whatever it doesn't matter they
resolve to pure entities or they resolve
to things that have some symbolic
structure left in them yeah I think
that's fine but my claim is that we'd
better have two functions for this no I
don't
how do you distinguish between the the
version like what if you don't want any
simplification okay fine
i okay that I agree with right so that I
agree with so in the transformation
collection right
these are resolution functions they
resolve as far as they can okay now you
are defining a collection of
transformation functions which do not
resolve they just sit there providing
something which at the moment of
resolution would be resolved am I making
sense yes yes since in some part what
what part doesn't make sense no I mean
what I'm saying is that this resolution
is has to be partial for any list I mean
even the fact that you're returning an
entity is means that you haven't
completely resolved because that's the
rule is the rule is resolution functions
resolve as far as they can as far as
they can when they are called
so entity value similarly might return
three or it might return an entity right
but it resolves as far as it can when
they are called
yes sense yes okay whereas whereas
transformation functions do nothing
transformation functions merely build
structure
right these returned virtual entity
classes that are merely symbolic
structures
and do no evaluation okay you go up to
the list of all the new symbols yeah
okay okay so these symbols are all
different so sort by and select can be
resolved aggregate join can't take can
extend can't extend thread can't okay
what do you mean by can be resolved so
you're saying means that they can be
stripped from the first argument of what
of entity okay so you're saying entity
list could resolve them yes could
resolve the first starting okay let's
take these functions again okay let's
let's go down here okay
okay so you're saying the first of these
let's call it sort identity class you're
saying that entity list is capable of
resolving that so entity list of a
sorted entity class would be would end
up with a list of entities correct
sorted that's that's not the difference
all of them can end up with a list of
entities okay so what's the issue so if
you have certain NC class of two
arguments you end up with the list of
entities that can have the first
argument okay so let's just understand
what the what's inside sorted entity
class so sorted entry Clause would have
an entity class here that might be our
g8 countries for example correct yes and
then the sorting criterion is
represented how in their property or an
entity function yeah or a rule if you
want to name the entity function okay so
let's imagine it's by population here
okay I'm not sure I'm not sure I totally
bought into that syntax but let's let's
if you do that then you could in
principle return for this entity country
Italy and she counts to China yep I
agree that's what you should do so okay
so now what's the next case so the next
case is something where you do not
believe you can resolve in the same way
give me an example of that the anti
aggregate so of entity aggregates so
that was aggregated entity class entity
class okay so let's look at that case
okay so what do you what what so
aggregated entity class so give me an
example here so now I've got the entity
class do I start off with an entity
class g8 for example here is that
correct
yeah yeah well if you do that you're
already in trouble yeah well okay so let
me get in trouble that's fine okay so
what's the second argument aggregated
into the clock and it would be something
like population goes to talk so what
does that mean that means that this is
what you have to do on the properties no
I'm not I'm not asking that yeah I won't
want to know okay what is the function
so this function here right is
ultimately a sort by of blah comma in
this case it will be hash of population
correct that's what that's all right I
mean in aggregated is a little bit more
complicated because it's like it can be
written with group bite but it's not
exactly group I because goodbye is
hierarchical and this isn't well we need
to understand that and maybe it isn't
quite the right function but okay but
this in this case this is sort by like
this right it's a little bit unclear to
me why okay and this is a shorthand
syntax for that right is this a
complicated case or is there an
intermediate case which is not as
complicated as aggregated we could look
at I think I've read is the first Muyo
one
well no identity extend actually simpler
and to the extent okay what is your new
proposed name for that standard density
class
all right let's take a look at that okay
so what would it stand identity class to
here
so are we giving it we're giving it say
country or or entity class country g8 if
you want let's do that okay then what
and then you would take a name let's say
density okay and that will go to entity
function of C comma C population divided
by C area okay so external entity class
is then so now for example one thing I
could do with this extended entity class
I see so now let's imagine that I do
entity list of that okay then in this
case you have no you have to plan I
understand I understand I understand so
in this case the the the entities that I
get out here are not pure countries
they're not pure g8 countries right
they're g8 countries that have been
extended by having this extra property
right okay all right so let's think
about how we represent that okay so I
mean some new construct here not really
like a Taipan annainsea class are kind
of the same structure algebraically it
may operate the same way when you apply
a property to them well okay so right
now we have an entity here France for
example right and what you are proposing
is that this first argument does no
inquiries
clearly an entity okay so the query
means this thing here right yes yes okay
but it's not really an entity in the
ending algebraically yes because if you
apply a property you get a scalar
oh yeah or more to the point so you're
making the okay so question what is the
difference between you know what is the
difference between entity types and
entity classes because that's in the
entity type position and it is not the
case that I can say right now entity I
don't believe at least entity of entity
class country g8
that doesn't work it doesn't work
another thing doesn't work but it means
something that's all how does that know
we can make it mean something
are you sure yeah I mean the thing is
that so in this case you can because
this is anchored by this would be just
like France but if you write entity or
entity class of country g8 comma room D
then you get non missing a moment no I
think you being I think like Inc look
also look is there there is a good
example here you know that Carla make
made it possible to work with the
computed entity classes where you just
say string goes suit and then the query
so that's string yes so so thing is
there is no fundamental difference
between entity types and energy classes
okay well let me let me come back here
okay this entity which you have named
France I don't think you can name
entities that way when you have a more
complicated entity type specifier here
this is purely a hack for this case
because this thing is a mere extrusion
extension of the country entity type
yeah but we had a proposal which is very
general how you can make this gaming
work three ways actually one is that we
get like some kind of Association
probably with some simple around it
because otherwise you could break in
pieces entities and and we use basically
property goes to the value so there's no
ambiguity another way is to make it
hierarchical and another way yet is to
flatten the hierarchical version the
version I currently have is flat and
hierarchical in the NT store for for for
when you register computer types no but
you're not addressing my issue my issue
is by the time you've got one of these
aggregated entity classes right you know
longa have a naming well maybe you are
addressing this issue no yeah I have a
naming convention internally I mean the
question is whether it's user friendly
enough if it's not user friendly enough
with the make it into an association so
it's very clear what it is you know I
have to say my feeling is that we should
have a notion of what we might call an
extended entity
okay because I think we're going to get
into trouble trying to put all this
computed stuff into our current entity
structure and my suggestion would be
than extend identity maybe that isn't
the right name is something which can
take both in its entity type and its
entity identifier
it can take arbitrary computed things
and an extended entity were it to
resolve to a simple entity that is a
base entity in entity stores that we
have you know built in or or
user-provided
it would then turn into that base entity
just as you know something like I don't
know some mathematical function of
something if it turns out it's PI
squared over 6
you know later of 2 if it turns out it's
you know because it's PI squared over 6
it resolves into that satyr of 3 does
not I I don't think it's a good idea to
have implicit evaluation of this stuff I
think it would be better to have an
explicit operation that does the
simplification but yeah why not and
maybe we can call it something like
computed entity and that thing it has is
this complex beast with the complex
first argument simplify and see if it
can peel off something out of it we
can't think I well fine I don't know
whether it should be on demand or or
automatic I have a feeling that's not
they need to be automatic i I think it's
dangerous too
I mean it's very important to entities
are symbolic signifiers and they don't
have valuation semantics I mean we can
we can add the double equal semantics
that would be fairly easy and very
useful to know whether an extension is
equal to an entity in some sense since
its least as a result that could be a
place where you apply certain
simplifications but not to the entities
themselves cell phone I live streamis is
commenting that he thinks that most of
the things we're talking about could be
mapped onto the data set to framework
and he doesn't understand what what what
we're doing here adds to that maybe
there's a quick way to describe that
okay I think that what this the
advantage of this over the data set is
that that is somewhat easier in a
valuation in this case that's not a good
enough answer to introduce some whole
giant structure just for the sake of
that
well another another answer steven is
that still we can work here with single
entities even though we are now
struggling with design but in the data
set you you can't do that you can only
work with data set and data set so I
think single and it is the existence of
single entities as a separate object is
the biggest issue here the biggest deal
so I'm sorry so what you're saying is
let me try to understand that I mean the
fact is data set is fundamentally an
array like object you know yes list of
associations associations whatever yeah
what this is is fundamentally an entity
store type object which is a collection
of you know entity property values it
does not have the same hierarchical
structure its data set but the question
is whether the data set query language
I mean who here thinks that they fully
understand the data set query language
do you all understand it properly or not
they never understood it okay that's not
a good sign I understood the I
understood it very well because I worked
with it internally okay by the way I
think that one thing word that data set
will like come to a grinding halt his
mutability in its current form yes but
there were suggestions about making
mutable data sets they just didn't went
they didn't go anywhere
um
okay look I want to come back to this
and and the understanding that we have
here right so what we're talking about
is this notion of transformations versus
resolutions okay and the issue is what
okay so one of the questions is when you
have a resolver that is fed things that
cannot be resolved what does it do
right like entity list is a resolution
function but you might feed it something
which simply cannot be resolved down to
literals and so to speak I'm a making
sense yeah I mean I think for as a
personal preference
I would really use more a function that
at least that doesn't try to resolve all
the way down but just resolves clearly
one level because I find it confusing
that you have some things that can be
resolved some things that can't tries
best effort than sometimes oh okay it's
different different uses for different
purposes I mean then in your world the
only resolver function is entity value
is that correct well not not necessarily
it would be useful sometimes to get
single entities but I don't then tell me
how you would get that no but imagine
you have something that is like let's
say computer that's Lister that's
returns computed entities and doesn't
try to resolve anything and so I want to
know the answer to the question of at
the end you have to resolve okay yeah
yeah what function do you want to use to
do that resolution but that's the end
that functions always that's devaluing
in case no no no no no I asked you the
question what how do you want to resolve
you say sometimes you want to resolve
what I'm seeing is this imagine I I want
to do entity some kind of entities which
is not until list and returned three
dressed computer dentists with weird
stuff in the first argument then I look
at them and I like copy-paste three of
them and then I apply an TD value to
that that's useful that's like you know
imagine you want to give some of your
customers and I got that right but now
the question I'm asking is in are you
saying that in your world that the only
resolver function is entity value that's
already the case no no it's not already
it's already a result is a resolver
function antilles but empty list imagine
you you write a notebook you take it
back five years later account three
stopped existing then you get an entity
that's not valid then that's not no
that's not the point I'm making that's
not the point I'm making the point I'm
making is right now there are eager
functions right so there are functions
that you're proposing these
transformation functions are basically
infinitely lazy functions right they
just produce a symbolic structure the
unresolved anything right yeah yes okay
so now what I'm saying is right now
entity list is an ego function that
attempts to resolve things right correct
yeah it has to some extent it never does
it fully because I don't care
its goal is to resolve it as far as it
can true or not true true okay and right
and in my point is that in my word I
would also need something that resolves
just one step
I get it I mean so you're proposing that
it is not resolved just one step it is
not a resolution function you want a
transformation function that makes a
list oh it's it's partially resolving
stone because just in order to get the
list of energies you still need to at
least get the names the economical names
so it needs to call it back ok all right
ok so that's it that's a tricky case but
for the time being let's imagine that
entity list is a resolve is an
infinitely resolver func resolving
function it maybe you're right
maybe that it's sufficient it may be
that every
use that we have today could be captured
by having a one-level resolving entity
list function someone saying yeah in
fact there is nothing which I don't know
if we discussed already or not but we
could even register some queries at
runtime so that they have string names
if they are complicated for the users
why not I mean technically we do that we
computed yes it does yes but my point is
that as every time when you are getting
some complicated looking for a target of
an entity an option would be to just
register this query so that it will look
simple if people do that look at this
idea this would be an unresolved an
entity with arbitrarily complex
unresolved stuff in its type or its name
or it's not in its naming its name its
results because it you need the names
you need to say continent to coast or
Europe no that's what the whole how do
you get a list out if you don't know
what the continents are okay
let's go through this again okay
is
okay well okay so I don't understand
this necessarily I don't understand that
part okay cien right this entity value
yep um class cross the word clock just
the symbol class like that yeah comma
like lower case it's not the like it's
just it's variable class Karma canonical
name okay canonical name is a string sir
okay and then map on this entity of
class hash entity and the open square
bracket class comma hash cross square
bracket and present map this is
basically what Angie's List does except
it simplifies class
or empty list is implemented on top of
entity value so it's a partial resolver
in that sense so the point is whether
class in the first argument or entity
should be the same class as the one in
it
you
clicking so
you
I mean my inclination would be yeah the
questions
entity itself can be overloaded to have
random crud in its first argument are
you saying that it wouldn't ever have
crud in its second argument second
argument can we can make it be at most
at least why what would it be a list of
a list of the so basically there is a
scheme in which you construct the the
primary key out of the query basically
so it's it's it's fairly simple because
for example as soon as you have an
entity aggregate then the third argument
of the aggregate is the properties that
form the conical name I mean I go
through the aggregate identity clause
for a second okay so first is what is
the definition of a great identity
clause
so it takes an entity class and what is
it going to do so remember our
definition of the sorted entity class is
it is related to sort by of this this is
the defining you know operation
basically I mean what's that yeah I mean
I I sent you this the code to implement
entity aggregate in in some notebook
maybe six minutes ago but it's me it can
be written on top of of sort by just
that what you mean sorry group by group
i okay so we we need defining code for
this just so we understand it yeah I can
fish it okay maybe if you can look in
that folder you have it it's it was
called something like Association
equivalent something like that so it's
kinda versions of these there may be
entree I can look um okay so
just explained them as they say in your
own words what does aggregated enter
closed so I believe entity class first
groups by the third argument
but what are the names of the argument
so let's start off with that
so the first class okay then the second
argument are aggregations and the third
arguments are aggregators oh my god
I mean aggregations we can call it
something else but that's how I
understand okay and the third argument
is optional
so if you omit the third argument to
aggregate you make one big rook so I can
go 18 by two true okay so what is an
example of an aggregation well the
aggregation is usually a string goes to
an entity function or maybe we can allow
some naked aggregators so where it what
what does this mean this means so tell
me again in your own words so to speak
what does aggregated entity class do
what is the one sentence it collapses a
whole entity class in this two argument
case into a single entity into OS a a
single don't entity class that contains
a one entity containing aggregated
properties of this class okay so
collapses all entities in class into
essentially single entity into a single
entity correct correct statement would
be that this is a a singleton entity
class not a single entity okay right
into it okay singleton entity class and
that single entity with that what
happened to the okay into a single
entity class in which what happened to
the property's original properties are
gone and the new ones are the ones that
there are there are no original
properties new properties
defined from aggregation a new process
define okay all right fine I understand
so now let me understand the
relationship between that and extended
entity class so let's let's write down a
little bit about what what happens here
so the Neum
so categories of function oops um so
what we're saying is there is a category
of function that is creating one
category of function creates a virtual
entity class
see I think there's gonna be a mess here
okay so one thing is so the first case
is extended entity class and what that
does is adds some new computed
properties to an existing entity class
correct is that correct yes okay now the
next one which I think is weird because
I think there's two different operations
here which are being conflated into one
oh they were separated than torn in
system to merge them okay what would the
separate I mean they were called
aggregated and agreed by one that's
different that's a different issue I
mean because this aggregated entity
class basically says um
take the whole entity class treat it as
an entity I understand it might be
multiple ones but but let's not worry
about that treated as an entity with a
new set of properties
derive from the original entity clause
correct yes yeah okay okay what are the
networks or some other cases here so
what is what is this one entity take
okay so entered a I mean I think we have
a new name for that which could be
something like bounded or sliced because
it's like you wanted a noun and then to
take its verb so it's like you're doing
exactly like take its it exactly like
take based on the number based on just
taking the first n entities yeah I mean
I guess I would like it to do up to
automatically because it's like would be
a mess if it evaluates and if it's
returns a message or something like that
but it also can take not necessarily the
first and it can take things from in the
middle yeah I mean just like they he can
do at least a second otherwise it's like
take take an opportunity let's try
something like this perhaps the best
name but that one is takes
um some it it's a slice
you think from m2n something like that
well I don't know what who calls that a
slice well or it's actually it actually
works a lot like spam also in language
okay where's the random one of these how
do I get a set of things from an entity
class
oh there's random entities so random
entity the function random entity yeah
okay so random entity I would like to
point out is another resolver in our
list of right are we forgetting anybody
else
so notice and you could end up with some
very bizarre lazy random entity what the
hell would that mean because there's two
type you know every time you call it
it's going to have a different you know
it's gonna throw the dice differently
yeah also throwing the dice in SQL is
not completely trivial we probably will
not support in version one well on the
on a server side yeah okay all right
fine but but
so this one is takes some
set of parts in an entity class of of of
the virtual lists corresponding to an
entity class right it's a some kind of
ordering now if you don't sort it before
you you might get an undefined behavior
depending on the background okay
so an alternative to this would be take
some set of parts of the virtual list
corresponding to entry class and gives a
new entity class
with that reduced set of functionality
reduced set of elements set of entities
okay so an alternative to this might be
something like
okay so I'm just give a name here
I mean an alternative thing I think
would be to be able to say with a
sorting criterion okay to be able to say
something like
and then the number of elements
I mean I'm thinking about look this is
like largest buy yeah it's like larger
Paget's take like take largest yeah as a
matter of fact you know what we could
like remove this and put it as an
argument as an optional argument sort to
sort an entity classes you mostly don't
want to do it unless you sorted before
right okay so that because it's like
take largest buy okay so let's now write
down the okay so let's now the case of
sorted entity class
the very same class but with its
ordering
defined by a sorting criterion
and maybe only the first n elements
extracted
I think there is a deeper semantic
problem here because we never we never
fixed the source that nature of all anti
classes that we're dealing with and so
if we don't say anything about it then
we can say what's happens what happens
if you take sorted into the class and
then for example do extend or do other
things so we will need to do to
introduce some notion of being sorted or
not as a property that can follow
through in the query I don't know why we
need that because in general if you
first do something like sort and then
you do something like extend then in
general you are not guaranteed that the
extended thing is going to be sorted
anymore and I found it quite down in
doing why I mean is this an SQL
implementation data yes but also in our
definitions if we say that entity
classes in general doesn't guarantee you
the order and all this transforms as
well then it doesn't guarantee you the
order I think this is something that we
have to fix in in in our implementation
but should not be a problem for the user
like it has this perk we should fix it
it's not as simple as that
because sometimes you don't care about
the order and I mean if you don't care
about the order you don't forget it
sorted we know it's it's an additional
overhead so you you do care in that
sense but I think yeah maybe we can
optimize that way but my question is
this do we in general assume that any
class like constructs are sorted yes
okay let's let's just have a quick look
at some things by the way someone on our
live stream is asking about why can't
you know they'd like to just query wiki
data and so on you will be happy to know
that in the new version
which I probably can't even pull up
things for we have a whole giant system
great that's still broken good Andrea
could you please report that again that
in the this is the prototype build right
that I'm running no it's the it's the
head branch build that it's not finding
documentation well can we find out what
actually went wrong that um okay so um
let's see back to this I was gonna say
that there's a new Sparkle whole system
for doing Sparkle queries that's coming
in version 12 that is yet again another
separate you know we've got Sparkle
we've got [ __ ] we've got SQL we've got
data set it is a bit of a zoo and it's
very frustrating that um but I think all
these things have different uses and the
sparkle one is the sparkle one is
directly integrated with entity store
and in fact you can you can basically
treat it like a giant entity store can't
you and now Tony has left so he he will
be the one to really represent that but
let's just look at entities select or
filtered entity class for a second and
explain to me what ok so I'm gonna write
that here because I think it's a little
bit better to find so filtered entity
class gives a new entity class with the
exact same entities
no not the exact cement with a subset
they filtered set of entities
okay so but these entities
still have the same types that they
always have don't they or do they not
that's the whole question like when they
are sorted when they are filtered you
could give them the same type or you
could want to know this is different
sorted and filtered are two different
cases I think no yeah no why because the
existence in a sort of thing is never
changing but in a filter it is yeah but
you're the mind
the aureus but at or order does not I
think it's the same thing like right now
the precedent that we have is like
complicit entity class disappears the
filter but you might want this mantiques
of keeping the filter to know when an
entity stops existing okay we've said
this multiple times here there is a
notion of of transformation functions
which are symbolic and infinitely lazy
so we're agreeing that we want such
things but I'm saying okay your your
point is it isn't even defined what this
entity class what this new entity class
is until you run a resolver function on
it like entity list yeah so it doesn't
really matter
still have the same if they if they get
resolved if they were immediately
resolved without some other operation
happening
okay so think we understand that one I'm
not sure I'm okay so what's the next one
of these is this horrifically
complicated to join a cross case
yeah it's not that complicated but true
okay so explain to me so with your
notion of merged entity clause explain
to me what is merged entity class so
imagine for example you have all the
countries and you want to add to merge
the country properties with the city
properties through the capital so that
you have this new mongrel entity which
is at the same time Italian Rome so
think about it is to enhance for example
the Rome properties with the properties
of the country Italy in this year right
right right right right so merge in
merges in the properties from one entity
class into another is that a way a
reasonable way to say it not quite
because this is the entity level
operation so it takes like entities
roughly speaking you can say it takes
entities of one class and adds to them
properties of the other one it's not
very it's very precisely either but it's
more precise than saying you're saying
that that it ok merges in into a
entity class well it actually what it
does if I'm not mistaken is it
associates with entities in a given
entity class entities from another
entity class is that right I mean there
is just one small thing like the case of
countering capital city is simple but if
you take persons and books one person
might write many books and one book
might be written by many people in that
case it has to multiply the roles and so
it's really like technically it's really
just a filtered version of the cross
product but okay associate with entities
entities from another class with
entities in a given class entities from
another class is that correct yes but
you can say that for each entity of one
class you can have several yeah right
maybe that maybe that that a single
entity in the first class is associated
with many entities in the second one
right okay listen we did not resolve
this today um can we please pick this up
again I have to go to this
machine-learning meeting so people who
are people on the livestream who are
interested in machine learning that is
what we're about to cover we just need
to continue this okay I will try to get
it this week again yeah maybe tomorrow
okay yes I will probably not be able to
attend tomorrow okay well you guys you
guys will broke other times okay um all
right frustrating we're not there yet um
I think we're let's try to remember next
time
this I think this notion of
transformation functions and resolution
functions is a useful notion I'm
optimistic let's let the okay and I
these names haven't made it yet for me
but let's keep pushing all right so
people on the livestream thanks for your
participation and we are going to those
interested in machine learning we are
about to talk about I'd supervised
machine learning functions in a couple
minutes makes a lot guys see ya bye
thanks